I have spoken to the party chairman Jake
Berry and he has confirmed that it will
be possible to conduct a ballot and
conclude the leadership election by
Friday the 28th of October so we should
have a new leader in place before the
fiscal statement which will take place
on the 31st I'll be able to give you
more details later on this afternoon
will members be included
the party chairman and discussed the
parameters of a process is to look at
how we can make the whole thing happen
including the party being consulted by
Friday next week
is a complete done
um it's certainly not a circumstance I
would wish to see it's like
it's like I think these are details that
will be clear later on I haven't got any
more detail to share with you now but
there will be some clarity later this
afternoon
are you in this this is the fourth
third-person the public must be looking
at us absolutely
um absolutely and I think we're deeply
conscious of the imperative and the
national interest of resolving this
clearly and quickly a general elections
are great they're not just be a general
election how can you continue this isn't
a matter isn't a matter for me will
there definitely be two candidates going
forward to the membership uh the party's
rules say there will be two candidates
unless there is only one candidate so if
somebody drops out if somebody drops out
it could only be one if there is only
one candidate there is only one
candidate
I really can't give you any more details
to have this contest truncated to one
week was it let's trust this idea or was
it your support I think uh I think it's
a matter on which there is a pretty
broad consensus